you
yeah watching my first vlog and I just
burned out also and I made a video last
night hands here was your first one yeah
baby
my first word where's Jaya Hey
slept in a little bit today I don't wake
up at 4:30 or 5:00 every single morning
it really depends upon what time I go to
sleep and last night I was at office
until midnight 12:30 I didn't get to
sleep until very late and I really do
need seven or eight hours so when I'm up
late I tend to sleep in and yes I am
sleeping in a tent on the roof there's a
whole story behind that essentially
Julie my wife she likes the bedroom a
lot warmer than I do I really need my
sleep environment to be quite cold like
60 to 64 degrees and she just freezes
like that and so when the bedroom is too
warm I just have a lot of difficulty
sleeping so I started this experiment
maybe eight or ten weeks ago where I got
a tent put it up on the roof and
immediately my sleep improved like
tenfold there's just something about the
cold evening air and being under you
know a bunch of blankets that just
knocks me out completely and I wake up
feeling so much that are so much more
rested so that's why I'm sleeping on a
tent and happy to talk about that more
at length later all right today is going
to be super busy which means one thing
- welcome back in today's seven
all right day two of the vlog I guess
this is happening
my biggest concerns are one
sustainability trying to find a way to
make this work on a daily basis not sure
how I'm going to do that and the second
thing is trying to figure out how to
make it engaging my biggest fear is that
it's going to be completely boring
because the truth is I kind of do the
same thing every day I train in the
morning I work in the afternoon I'm with
my kids my family not that much exciting
stuff happens most of my day is staring
at a computer screen and so how do I
make that interesting or compelling in a
vlog format so I don't know the answer
to any of these questions but I suppose
that is the creative challenge and
that's what's interesting and compelling
to me tackling that challenge all right
I'm going to the pool see all this this
is what I love about this pool most of
the time it's old lady glasses and a
bunch of senior citizens enjoying the
day and it's not that crowded so I don't
have to fight for a lane and beautiful
morning
I always feel so much better after
something now I got to go into town I
got 45 minutes to get to Venice I think
I'm going to be late I'm taking old
Topanga which is kind of a shortcut and
really scenic
maybe to Venice
only a little bit late hello hi oh yeah
of course we have a French one
hello in C sky okay that's a great
zombie Amon dumb rich hearty thanks for
having me but we're videoing the whole
thing right that's Vidya it's not just
on okay okay
and then we're recording the whole thing
and then when it's all over I'll maybe
record a video of just asked for like 30
seconds yeah sure like a teaser to the
podcast yeah gotcha in addition to
periscope it's called dinner party yes
right the dinner party with Elisabeth
Alfano gotcha we're dinner party chg oh
and the dinner party TV so we're live on
periscope and your meeting means I am
video I know I've been cooking all
morning I have to say so hopefully like
this kernel I have a higher buddy I have
a live television show in Chicago what I
do is I invite three celebs who don't
know each other and a promise check who
cooks for them and everyone in the
audience and that was so popular in
Chicago that I decided to come out here
to LA see how things would go up here
and bring the podcast version of that
show so the show is so popular in
Chicago that WGN Radio asked me to do a
podcast of it and that's what I'm doing
here in LA
here I love it so we're podcasting or
periscoping and we're vlogging all the
same oh and we're eating or yeah that's
what we're doing alright okay so I'm
gonna put this down so I can focus on
the food but this looks beautiful
oh thank you the podcast is over
now did I do okay you're fab yeah you're
telling it like it is and eating so I
love you will come to my house and
actually eaten I don't usually get fed a
podcast so this was great yes I didn't
have time to go eat on my way here and
this is perfect so three salads
desert all right podcast with Elizabeth
was over that's the first time I've been
when I was a guest on podcast which is
great
feel-good and I was going to head back
up the coast home but since I'm party
down here and it's so beautiful out
I think I might go for a run I wasn't
planning on running today but
unbelievably windy out I already have
sand in my eyes
all right switching to GoPro oh my god
that is the windiest I've ever seen it
here I had to abandon the GoPro it just
became like too much it was crazy
just like a half an hour easy jog shake
out the legs that was a no big deal but
nice to get active come out and check
out this window it's unbelievable I
doubt you can tell from the video but
trust me it's like tight feeling wind I
got a ton of work I got to do but before
I go back to the office there's one last
thing that I just can't resist doing
I gotta jump crazy
feel like a new person
totally rejuvenating all right now I'm
ready to go to work still in the office
the struggle is real and vlog two is
over